εότητα έναν διαρς άγχος να συνετοποιούμε σιγά σιγά ότι έπρεπε να κοινηθούμε με τρόπους καιμεριθμούς
που δεν είχε ξαναγίνει για την υγεία και ότι ήταν όλα καινούρια ήταμια προτόγνωρι παγκόσμεακρίσει
δεν ήταν μια κρίσι που επηρίαζε μια χώρα η μόνο την ευρωπαϊκή ένωση πηρίαζε όλον
τον πλανίτη και ι αυτό έπρεπε νανα βρούμε λύσεις για προβλήματα τα οποία κανείς δεν
είχε ξανασυναντήει χτυπά το τηλέφωνο της τέλας κυριακήδου για της λένε για τα πρώτα κρούσματαπως
μιώθετε καίνεται στιγμη όταν ενημερώθηκα για τα πρώτα περιστατικά του κόβιςστην στην ευρώπη η πρώτημο
αντίδραση ήταν πρώτο να ενημερωθώσωστα από τες υπηρεσίες μο ολά το δεύτερο ήταν να επικοινωνίσω
άμεσα με τους υπουργούς γείας που επηριαστήκαν ιχώρεσ τους για να ξέρουν ότι είμαστε εκε
αυτό ήταν αν θέλετεγια μένα ο τρόπος που μπορούσαν να κρατήσω μαζί τ τακσεφτά κρατημέλι
αμέσωση που επικοινωνούσαμε τον υπουργό συγκεκριμένα το μεγάλο θέμανητα στην ιταλεία νανθυμάστε είμαστε σε καθημερίνη
είναι επαφη είχαν το κινητόμου μπορούσαν να με πάρουν κοστέσθερις ώρες το κοστετράορ να μου
πουν το πρόβλημα που αντιμετωπίησαν και να προσποθήσω εγώ να υρολήσεις να τους στηρίξουμε και
με αυτό τον τρόπο χτσαμε αυτό που πιστεύ δεν είχε ξαναγίνει στα θέματα εγείας μια
ευρώπι ευρωπαϊκή ένωση που είχε μια συνεργασία και μια ληλεγκή στο ότι αντιμετωπίσομε μαζί αυτή
την πρόκληση όταν μάθεται για την κύπρο ήταν και οικογένεια σας εδώ τι τη σκεφτικά
τε φοβηθεί κάτε